INSTRUCTOR: Hi, everyone.
Welcome back.
Hopefully, after
last video, you have
at least a high-level
understanding
of what the cloud is.
I want to dive into it today
and get a little bit more
in detail of some
of the tools you're
going to be leveraging
in the cloud, why we're
going to be using those, and
also address this question I
highlighted as a potential issue
at the end of the last video
that there are costs associated
with leveraging the cloud.
Again, I don't want that to
be a fearful or scary thing.
That is a positive,
arguably, that we
have a platform that allows
us to pay as we go on this.
So we're going to learn how to
leverage that and preempt some
of those costs and understand
what the potential costs are
coming into that.
So with that, and I guess I'll
slide myself out of the way
first.
All right, let's see here.
Dropped my slides.
There we go.
And now-- All right,
good technology, right?
So there.
So you should hopefully have
already created an AWS account.
If you haven't, come
to aws.amazon.com.
On the top right here,
mine says complete sign up
because I had started
the process of signing up
for a new account, but
either way you'll just
have a sign up button there.
If you haven't signed
up already, click that.
It's the usual sign up
for an account step,
so I won't bore you by walking
through that, though, again,
as I mentioned, you will
have to put a card on file,
so just be aware of that.
Nothing is being
charged upfront,
and we'll talk about
that specifically today.
So putting the card on file will
have no risk associated with it.
But if you have any issues with
that, feel free to reach out
and we can find workarounds.
But either way, you're
going to come over here
once you have an account,
sign in, and that
will bring you to a page that
looks something like this.
You should see this.
This is technically
the new sign in UI.
Depending on when you're
seeing this video,
this might be the default, so
I won't bore you with that.
But regardless,
you'll have a choice
of either the kind of root
user login or the IAM user.
We'll have a whole separate set
of videos discussing IAM users.
This is a really important
and powerful feature
we won't get into now, so you'll
likely just do the root user.
This will be your
email address that's
used to create an account.
This user-- basically
the root user--
has access to anything
and everything.
That's the reason why
the IAM user is powerful.
The root user is
technically something
we should only use for very,
very specific use cases
because they can do
anything and everything.
So if that password ever gets
compromised, that can be a risk.
So moving forward,
we'll start to work
towards using only IAM
users where we can restrict
the level of resources.
So either way, for now,
we'll just use the root user.
So you're just going to
put in your email address.
I just have password saved
to my password manager,
so we won't worry about that.
And then I have
multi-factor authentication.
I would encourage you
all to set this up.
And again, in a
couple of lectures,
we'll talk about
how to set this up.
I'm just using an authenticator
on my phone that gives me
basically a passcode that is
changes every 30 seconds or so,
but this is a good
way to ensure, again,
some security around this.
So even if somebody steals
my root user password,
they would have to
have my phone, which
is the only device that
is connected to it, that
has access to it, so there's a
couple layers of security there.
But either way, when
you come in here,
you'll see this is what the
AWS platform looks like.
I'll refer to this throughout
the semester as the AWS console.
So anytime I say
the console or let's
open up the console,
that is what I'm seeing.
You can see it up here.
Even they call it that as well.
C-O-N-S-O-L-E. So the console.
Either way, this is kind of
the home base for everything
and anything in AWS.
We'll use this a ton.
Your goal this
semester is to just
get completely comfortable
with anything and everything
in this platform.
You can already see here,
right on this home page,
I have an estimated cost and
usage on the AWS platform,
so it's very clear where
costs are coming in,
and you can see mine are showing
forecasted end of month assuming
the steady rate of usage I have
this month we'll be at $20.
But I'll say that
this specific account
is running a live application
in production that has probably
10 or 20 users using it.
So this is for something that
is pretty heavily used already.
I'm only spending
about $20 a month.
So costs are very,
very low on this.
There's no other subscription
costs just to use AWS.
The platform is the platform.
So at its core--
and we'll get into this a lot
throughout this semester--
there's the EC2 and S3.
I want to highlight
these two because these
get at the core components
of what cloud computing tends
to be built around.
It is compute and storage.
Compute being that I
have a virtual machine--
a computer in the cloud--
and storage-- I can store files.
So like your Google
Drive is some storage.
And so by leveraging-- so
EC2 is Easy Cloud compute.
That's what that
acronym stands for.
That is kind of the
core component-- this
and S3, simple storage service.
These are the two
core components
that basically the rest
of AWS is built off of.
Everything else is--
or not everything else
but most things are just
kind of a software layer
on top of these
two resources here.
These will be what we use
the most again this semester.
And this is also
what is typically
referred to as
infrastructure as a service.
This is-- IaaS being
the acronym here--
it's called that because this is
us saying, hey, all we're doing
is getting access to the
bare metal, basically.
We're saying we want access to
a computer and a hard drive,
and we will do all the software
and everything on top of that.
The nice thing about that
is we have complete control,
but that does come at
the expense of more
effort and development.
So that would be of this
infrastructure as a service
idea.
Then remember, we said
that a layer up from that
is the platform as a service,
where platform as a service
is something that
says, OK, well,
you don't want to have to
manage every detail about these,
but you're doing quite
a bit of involved work.
So Elastic Beanstalk,
for example,
that is part of
AWS that would be
called a platform as a service.
It allows you to host and deploy
applications, web applications,
websites but not have
to actually allocate
the individual resources.
So for example, right now, this
website here that I'm running,
I'm actually running
it through Heroku.
That's what this is right here.
Heroku is another
platform as a service.
It's an entirely
separate thing from AWS.
We won't get into
that right now.
We'll do this later
on in the year.
But this is just a
place where I can go to
and I say, hey, I have code for
a website that I want to launch.
I don't want to have to
manage the underlying
computers because maybe there's
a bunch of users one day,
and then the next day
there's not a lot of users,
so I want something that kind
of automatically adjusts.
And so I can come in here
and specify the max amount
of resources I can leverage.
So you can see, for example,
I'm on a plan that says we're
going to max out at $7 a month.
We might not necessarily
use all $7 a month.
We might not have
it always available,
but I'm going to allow
them to dynamically scale
my resources in the back end.
So infrastructure as a service--
I have complete
control of everything.
I have to choose how
many computers exist,
what storage we're using.
Platform as a service--
I have to decide what is
going on to this platform,
but I'm not actually managing
the low-level resources.
And then one level
above that, or kind
of the final level of that,
is software as a service.
Again, I would liken
software as a service
to using something like-- even
for that matter, Google Drive.
While Google Drive is
giving us access to storage,
I'm not actually allocating
the underlying resources.
I'm not having to write
some script that says,
hey, when I put a file
in here, make sure
you connect more storage space
or if I expand my account
to go from 100 gig platform
to a two terabyte platform.
I don't have to manage
it at that level.
All I do is go in
here and drop a file.
Or again, Google
Docs is another thing
that would be a
software as a service.
Really, most of the
internet we interact with--
Spotify, you could argue
is software as a service.
They give us access
to music and playlists
and all sorts of other
features, and all
we interact with is the
software layer of this.
They have everything else
managed on the back end.
And they, for that matter,
might leverage certain things
that our platforms as a
service, or they might leverage
infrastructure as a service.
So these things are all
sorts of intertwined aspects
of the cloud.
And it's not that critical
that you necessarily
know what is infrastructure
versus platform versus software,
but I just wanted
to introduce you
to it because these
sorts of vocabulary words
are used quite a
bit in the industry.
So just as you are going
around and starting
to look at careers and more
opportunities in space,
you'll have understood the
differences between these words.
But either way, that's
too in the weeds
on just a small aspect of this.
But again, like I said,
most of this semester
is going to be centered
around EC2, which gets
us a computer in the cloud.
Then there's going
to be S3, which
gets us storage in the cloud.
We will at some point start
talking about databases.
RDS-- Relational
Database Service--
is Amazon's version of
a database in the cloud.
Now surprise, it's
built off of EC2 and S3
because all the database
is is a bunch of storage
with some software
on the front end
to make a nice clean
interface with that code.
We will spend some time
talking about lambda,
which allows us to
do what's called
serverless computing, where
again we don't interact directly
with the bearer or the
core infrastructure that
is backing this.
We just write some logic that
just executes at whatever scale
it needs to.
So there's all
sorts of resources
here, and in all honesty, if you
want to really spend some time,
click on Services
here on the top left
and just start clicking through
all of the different software
pieces that have been built
on top of AWS or within AWS.
These are all managed
tools and technologies
that you can leverage,
and honestly, they
may be of interest to you
for your final project.
You're more than welcome for
your final project to say,
hey, I'm really interested
in game development,
so I'm going to look
at building a kind
of bare bones, super minimal
game using Amazon GameLift.
Or maybe you're really
interested in what
the opportunities for
quantum computing are,
and so you can click on Amazon
Braket, where you actually
go in here and
build a algorithm,
let's say, that is tested on
a simulated quantum computer,
and I believe you can actually
leverage physical quantum
computer.
You deploy your
algorithm or test it
onto a real quantum computer.
So I mean, the level of detail
and opportunity around here--
I mean, it's just limitless.
There are so many things
to build within AWS,
so I would encourage
you to take some time,
click on all these
things, see what
might be of interest to you.
You will get very clear
insights into if something costs
before you actually run it.
So, for example, if I come in
here and click on AWS DeepRacer.
This is a fun little
tool or product
that exists within AWS to
test autonomous driving
and build and test
autonomous driving
with a physical bit of
hardware that you can buy.
Look through these things,
see what's going on here,
and see what kind of
sparks your interest.
I mean, the best way to learn
anything, but specifically
in this cloud computing
space, is to find something
that matters or is at
least of interest to you.
If it's just me talking
about the kind of pieces
that are interesting
or relevant to me,
it might not hit the same.
So take some time, explore
that, play around with it.
Come talk to me if you have
other questions related to it.
The one other thing I
wanted to talk about today,
though, was to get
you exposed to how
to start to estimate prices.
So first thing I'll
show you is actually,
if you're ever curious,
what something costs,
or better statement,
what the free tier is,
just search AWS free tier.
It'll pull you up this page.
I think it's the
one I'm looking for.
Yeah, this one right here.
So this shows you basically
what is available to you
under Amazon's free tier.
There are three
types of free tiers.
There are these things that
are just like free trials
where you'll say like, hey,
I'm allocated x amount of time
or resources within this tool
for a certain amount of time.
There'll be those
that are always
free that are again, at any
point you can use them for free.
And then these are
the ones I just
wanted to highlight because
these are things that
are available to you for
free within the first 12
months of you
opening your account.
So if you've created an account
before more than a year ago,
then these will not be
under the free tier for you.
But if this is the first time
you've created an account,
you will have 12 months from
basically when that account was
created to 12 months from
now-- a year from now--
to use these tools
at their free tier.
So they will still be
limited, but they'll
give you some more
opportunity to really explore
and dive deep into this.
So, for example,
this is probably
the most relevant one for what
we're going to do this semester.
If you have a
completely new account--
and also if you have an account
for more than a year ago,
I am not going to
be offended or upset
if you create a new account
under a new email address.
I do not work for AWS, so
that is none of my business.
You can go create a separate
account and fallback
within the free tier again.
The only downside
is if you have stuff
that's on that other
account, you'll lose that,
but that's another way to jump
right back into the free tier
if you're just kind of
in the exploration phase.
But either way, this
is what we're going
to use a lot this semester.
So for certain-- again,
remember that EC2--
Easy Cloud Compute-- that
is a computer in the cloud.
It's a computer sitting
in some data center
somewhere that we are
connecting to remotely.
For that, if you use certain
types of those instances--
where again, an instance is
an instance of that computer
in the cloud, they're
defined by these kind
of alphanumeric names,
then dot some size.
So T2 micro, T3 micro.
You'll see T4 small--
all that kind of stuff.
But if you're using certain
instances with certain operating
systems, they will be free
for 750 hours per month.
And if we do the math,
I think it comes out
to basically 30 days exactly.
It's 24 hours a day, and for
31 days would be 744 hours.
So yeah, it's just over--
or enough time to give
you just over a month
of a single computer running
live in the cloud per month.
So it's per month for
the first 12 months.
So this is what I'll
be using to leverage
to keep us doing most of the
stuff we do in this class
under the free tier.
Now, if you are outside
of that free tier,
I'll show you in a second
how we can estimate
what those costs are, but
this will be the thing
that we want to leverage most.
So within this 12 months of
first opening the account,
you'll basically have a single
free instance for a whole month.
Now, there's also the reality
that we will oftentimes only use
an EC2 instance for an hour
during the lecture, in which
case you could just terminate
the instance at the end of that
and that's not going to be
running against your 750 hours.
So you could technically have
more than just one EC2 instance
running, but again,
in total they
have to sum up to
under 750 hours
and again, specifically only for
these size instances and those
using the operating system, in
this case of the Linux, Red Hat
Enterprise Linux.
I forget what SLES is,
but another Linux flavor.
Or again, you can use Windows
at the T2 micro or T3 micro
in this.
We're going to do everything
mostly under an Ubuntu instance
specifically, which we'll talk
about later, but that's one.
The other one I
wanted to point out
that we're going to use a
lot this semester is S3.
You get five gigs of free
storage for your first 12
months.
We'll look at how to
estimate the cost of that
once we start talking about
S3, but that'll be plenty
if you're within that 12
months for everything running
this semester.
We're not going do anything
close to five gigs.
And actually, technically, we
will also use RDS as well too.
So another one that
can be good to be
able to leverage free tier.
But in general, you'll see
there's a ton of things, like,
for example, AWS Lambda.
I talked about that.
That gets you one million
free requests per month.
We'll see what that
means later on.
But that one is always
free, so you always
get a million free requests
per month to Lambda services.
So there's quite a few
different tools out there,
and so depending on what
you're interested in,
feel free to look.
It's like we said,
the game tech.
If you want to
play with GameLift,
you get 125 hours free in your
first 12 months of GameLift.
So just come here to this
page, see if what you're doing
has an option for a free tier,
what you can play around with.
So that's the first
thing I want to show.
Then there's also-- and
I guess I'll show you
how I got to this page.
If you want to estimate the
cost of using an EC2 instance,
I would just search
EC2 pricing calculator,
and that'll bring
you to this page,
or you can just go
to calculator.aws--
have a nice clever little thing.
But this is how you can estimate
the cost of an EC2 instance
or really any service
in AWS as well,
and this will be useful
for this assignment
that you're going to have
to do related to this.
But either way, if you come
here, the first thing to note,
and you'll actually see
this on the AWS console page
here, at the top
right-hand corner,
there are different
regions, so we'll
get into this in
the next lecture,
but these regions of AWS
are completely isolated.
I won't say completely isolated.
They have connections so you
can transfer stuff between them,
but the idea is that these are
kind of broad regions of AWS
with multiple data centers
within each region,
but the different
regions sometimes
have different
available services
and also they may have
different available pricing.
I'll typically use
either US West one or two
because those are the ones
that are closest to me
geographically, and so that
means that technically speaking,
I'll get the fastest speeds.
I mean, as you'll see, they're
not meaningfully different.
Light travels fast.
So really, honestly, any
of these would be fine,
but I would definitely
stay within the US
and probably, again, stay
with one closest to you.
That matters in the
pricing too, so that's
why I wanted to show you that.
So for example, here
I'm going to look for--
I'm going to do
search for service,
and I'm just going to type in
EC2 and then click Configure.
Notice I'm in US East
Ohio, but I could also
do US West North California.
They both have EC2, and I
think actually every region
has EC2 instances available.
So once I come here
now, you can see
in the bottom left-hand
corner, I can already
see the costs there.
Some things have
upfront costs where
I have to pay an upfront fee.
Others have monthly costs.
Some things have both.
It might be that--
because some services allow you
to basically pay some amount
upfront to get a discounted
monthly cost and all
that good stuff.
So it's just worth knowing that
there are different options.
But either way,
like I said, we're
going to use the Linux
operating system.
I don't even think--
yeah, we can't even
specify a different
one or we can't
specify just regular Ubuntu,
so we'll just put Linux for now
and we'll just focus
purely on constant usage.
There might be things where
you're going to have down
the road-- again, this is
not something we're getting
into this semester--
where you have to account for
spike traffic or something
like that, but when
you get to that point,
you'll know that that'll
be necessary for you.
More importantly, though,
is if you come down here,
you can see these are all
the different types of EC2.
There's 48 pages of
it of different types
of EC2 instances we can use.
As I said, the instance name is
always some alphanumeric string
and then a size after it.
So nano, small, but I think
they even go up to 2XL.
There's larges.
Let's see if I can
skip towards the end.
Does that give me some--
Yeah, so 32XL.
So you can see there's
a huge variety,
and this column right
here actually shows you
on demand hourly
cost, so what it
costs you to pay per hour to
use a machine of this size.
So you can see this one
here costs $35 per hour.
So that's where I say again,
if you were to spin this up
in the background, not
realize you did it,
and then never
delete it, in a day,
you would be spending
hundreds of dollars on this.
I say this from personal
experience having done this.
So that's why I just
want to point out
these things can be expensive.
The same token,
though, let's actually
look at what the
resources are here.
So this machine right
here-- this x2iedn.32xl--
this thing has 128 vCPUs.
Remember we talked about CPUs
last time in the last lecture?
128 virtual CPUs,
what they call them,
but basically treat
them like a single CPU,
and 4,100 gigs of memory,
so four terabytes basically
of memory.
And that's again RAM.
That is the kind of
ephemeral storage.
That's the really
expensive stuff.
And two-- I think
these are in gigs.
Don't quote me on that.
I think it is in gigs of NVMe.
So this is really,
really fast storage.
So what is that?
Yeah, like four-ish
terabytes potentially
of fast storage on board,
and you can always add more.
I want to show you what an
equivalent computer would
cost if I were to try to
spec something out like this.
So I'll go to Newegg,
which is just a site where
you can buy computer parts.
And so again, we're looking
for, let's see here,
128 CPUs and 4,100
gigs of memory.
So if I'll come over here, go to
computer systems and let's just
go to desktops and I'm just
going to do desktop computers,
desktop computers.
We just want all desktops.
So let's see if we
can filter this down.
I don't even know if I can
filter based on core count,
but let's see if we can.
So maybe not.
Let's do power search.
I might have to look
up what, specifically,
a 124 core-- but let's just
do it based off of the RAM.
So if I go to here for memory
capacity, you'll notice--
and this is again RAM.
If I'm looking at DDR4
memory, the biggest computer
I can buy off the shelf
has one terabyte of RAM,
and we were showing a machine
that had four terabytes of RAM,
so let's just filter
just on that alone.
I'm not even going to worry
about the other things.
So that's one terabyte of RAM.
Let me see this.
Yeah, I don't think this
first one is appropriate
because that does not look
like it is near enough cost.
Maybe it is.
But you can see the rest
of these machines here.
These are probably
more realistic.
I wouldn't trust this version.
These are probably more
realistic to what the cost is.
This is a 64-core machine with
a terabyte of RAM and eight
terabytes of NVMe storage.
So maybe not exactly
right, but getting
close to what the
spec of that computer
was that we were going
to spin up in the cloud.
And this one's about $25,000.
So if I'm doing some tasks that
really needs that much compute
resources, I have a choice now.
I can either go and buy a
$25,000 computer potentially,
or let's say we can get some
deal because we don't actually
need all of these things, and
maybe we don't need the graphics
card-- all that stuff.
Let's say generously, we
can get some this $15,000.
$15,000, or alternatively, I
could get this machine with four
terabytes of RAM, so four times
the RAM of that other machine
and 128, so twice
the number of cores.
So again, we are
really kind of still
significantly above the compute
capacity of the other machine.
And if I do even just
15,000 divided by 35,
I'd have to use this thing for
428 hours before I would match
the costs, or again, 17 days
would be the end days amount.
So 17 days of 24 hour
usage or I have to--
or at that point, it would
be more cost-effective to buy
the kind of full price machine.
But again, likely is
going to be the case--
and this is often how it
is with a lot of computing,
where it's like, I
need that machine
for a small period of time to
do some really big operation.
And then I can do everything
else on a small machine.
So this is typically
how I'll work,
is that I will
instead use something,
let's say, T2 micro to do all
of my software development,
all my building, testing
and everything like that,
make sure things broadly work.
And then once I know I
need the big machine,
I'll spin it up for
one, two hours a day,
whatever it is that I need,
and then shut it down,
and I'm done with it.
And you can see
that equivalently
or by comparison,
T3 micro, let's say,
costs just over $0.01
per hour to run.
So that is getting
to such a low cost.
And this is why I say even if
you're outside the free tier,
as long as you're diligent
about this and not spinning up
100 machines and not
shutting them down,
this is not going to
cost you too much.
So again, let's say
we use T3 micro,
we forget to shut it
down for the whole month
and it's just running
the background,
you're looking at
$5.18 to run that.
And that machine has two
cores, one gig of RAM,
so it's going to
get the job done.
Then if we come
down here, we can
see that we can also add
on Elastic Block Storage.
Again, you can view this as just
adding memory, or not memory
necessarily, so much a storage
hard disk, hard drive space.
So we're not worrying
about S3 yet.
This is going to be
our hard drive space.
And so let's say I wanted to
have a hard drive, like what
did this machine have.
This thing had a 10
terabyte hard drive.
So I could come
in here and choose
a storage amount
of let's say I just
wanted 1 terabyte of storage.
So you can see there that would
bring my total monthly cost
to $103.
And I don't know if we can
show the hourly rate of here.
I'd rather see the hourly.
Yeah, here we go.
Perfect.
So you can see here
what the hourly rate is
and what that individual
EBS storage cost is.
Or maybe I only
need 100 gigabytes,
and that brings the
cost down quite a bit.
So either way, if you
ever want to test out
what the cost of a
computer is, this
is where you're going
to want to do it at.
This is all you'll need to do.
Is just come into here,
start to play around
with some of these things and
see where those costs are.
I think the one other
thing I wanted to show--
yeah, I skipped over it
right here for a second,
but there are opportunities
to reduce the cost.
Actually, that's not correct.
I was showing you using
this compute savings plan.
This is the more
apt description.
So if I click this
on demand button,
you see the price changed a
little bit there to 1,865.
This is what we're
going to be doing,
is everything we're going
to be doing this semester is
on demand where it's like,
hey, I want to use it now
and I know I'm going
to need it now,
but I don't know how long
I'm going to need it.
If you know in advance,
let's say you're a company
and you know that you have all
of your employees leverage EC2
instance in the cloud
every day, you can pay up
or you can reserve
instances such
that you can reduce
the cost per month.
So you can see this drops
the cost pretty significantly
per month using this compute
savings plan or this instance
savings plan.
So note that there
are alternative costs
or alternative approaches here.
You can also similarly pay
upfront, partial upfront,
all that good stuff.
The spot instances, I
don't use them typically
because it would require
a very specific use case.
The idea with these
is that let's say
I have a process
that I need to run,
but I don't necessarily
need it to run now
and I have any sort of
immediate timeline for it.
A spot instance
says, OK, well, when
there's some excess
compute capacity,
go ahead and allocate it to me.
And usually these will
be a little bit cheaper.
And you can assume
percentage discounts
and go through all of
that, if that's the case.
Again, that's a very
specific use case.
So broadly speaking,
I focus on on-demand.
So that's really most of what
I wanted to talk about today.
What I'll say now is there's
a set of slides for the Unit 1
project that are up on Canvas.
They'll look
something like this.
And they have a couple
different scenarios on there.
Let me double check the
assignment real quick,
but I believe all I'm asking
you to do for this assignment is
to pick one of these.
Let me see here really quick.
And you can just review
this on Canvas as well, too.
I mean, you have to wait
for me to read this.
Yeah, for one.
So what I want you to do is
pick one of these categories
and price them
using a cloud option
or using AWS versus buying an
on premise computer, let's say,
for it.
So you can just use
Newegg, like I just did,
to find an equivalent computer.
And basically, you're
going to be looking
for RAM, storage,
number of CPUs,
and whether a GPU
is needed or not.
We didn't talk about
pricing of GPUs,
but I'm leaving that as kind
of a fun extra experiment
for you to figure out how to
do this or how to price those.
I'll give you a hint that
certain instances have GPUs, so
certain types of instances.
So basically, you need to look
up what types of instances
have a GPU on board
or not, and each GPU
will also have its
own associated VRAM,
how much memory is on
board the GPU specifically.
So there's VRAM,
there's regular RAM.
And also you're welcome
to use ChatGPT or search
or any other tools to help you
make a sense of how to do this.
There's no, there's no integrity
issues or anything like that.
So definitely search,
use all the tools you
have at your disposal.
But what I want you to do is try
to price these and see basically
what the trade
offs and costs are
and what is a better option
for these different use cases.
In this case, they're using it
for a web application server.
This case, they're using it
for data science workstation.
So this is starting to
work you towards the work
that maybe solutions architect
or a systems architect might do
is to say like, hey, my
employees need resources
for this task.
This is a trade
off situation here
where it's like what is the most
advantageous thing for us to do.
And ignoring some of
the other extra costs,
but just from a pure cost of
hardware standpoint, which
one is cheaper for us to
do in our circumstance
or for a certain amount of time?
All of these will have a
time trade off is to say,
at some point this
might be cheaper.
So either way, there's
no real rigid rules
around how to do this.
I just want you to
start to explore
what are the associated
costs with doing one,
or if you're curious,
you can do all of them
of doing this on premise.
So basically looking
for this on Newegg
versus doing this in the
cloud, so using something
like EC2 pricing calculator,
I'll say the one other thing to
note is for the number of cores
or for the number of these
CPUs, a lot of times it can--
for physical hardware, you'll
see this listed as cores.
There's a lot of
subtlety in here.
So if you are a
computer engineer at--
you'll recognize that there's--
I'm being a little loose
with the verbiage here,
but for the context
of this course,
it's perfectly fine to treat one
core as equivalent to one vCPU,
as they define them here.
So you see, these are
vCPUs and these are cores.
Treat those as one to one for
our use case as perfectly fine.
Otherwise, good luck.
Feel free to reach out to me.
If you have questions or
concerns, come by office hours
or just set up a time
with me otherwise.
So, yeah, have fun
and look forward
to seeing what you
guys put together.